would you stop playing Pupa shot he's
not an arcade game for sake wait is his
voice just gonna be like that from now
on yeah but nobody's gonna notice
[Music]
the last few months have been a
repairing the ship on weekends slogging
through that boring ass office job from
now on I'm the boss baby well not the
boss baby but I am your boss baby damn
it now I want a bottle of milk
don't exercise in the daytime a big part
of the mission is US fitting in on Earth
everyone looked like a perfect non-weird
family why do you have to be like this
too long
[Music]
the Wall could be frozen over in two
months everyone will die Jesse will save
us all four hi there little friend did
you get lost what's your name my name is
you know how we've been trying to find
something that will complete us as a
family it's the theme of the Season make
us a dinosaur
drop that beat one two a one two three
four
[Music]
as the pupa specialist let me say he's
fine wait where is he
thank God he was just sleeping forgot
how he looks super ugly when he sleeps
opposites are going on eruption
okay this time daddy got us a regular
bus with almost no bombs maybe yeah baby
you're human oh my gosh do you have a
butthole I don't know you tell me
he's got a butthole
oh
[Music]